[Music]
in God complex news mm submitted by he
rock again love from India
hello I love Indian food me too
I love it and the Taj Mahal the man who
invented the blue whale suicide game
aimed at children says his victims are
biological waste and that he is
cleansing society what the [ __ ] is this
blue whale suicide this sounds [ __ ]
nuts
what is this blue whale sounds like an
ecstasy pill oh yeah let's get some blue
whales or [ __ ] Coachella so you guys
haven't heard of blue L came at all nah
I don't keep up what you tell me about
it what is it you suffocate yourself yep
ding ding in your face turns blue solar
cycle whale no no you're like me yeah is
it a real video game no it's not an
actual like video game they play so what
this game it so pretty much what this
game so pretty much okay I'm just trying
to like gather my thoughts and like okay
how do I be big no like there's so much
info info in this story so this game
started in Russia and this man that
we're talking about he's a 21 year old
that had been arrested in connection
lodomeria shmakov Phillips wow that was
way off the lease Russian name my name
is love here it's not hello he's a
former psychology students he was
expelled from his new University growing
up he was always a loner he is mom was
never home she works a lot sounds like a
psychopath
so back in 2013 he started creating
these suicide clubs or they must be mad
about that many pet members we need
recruiting sheep they keep disappearing
this all began with F 57 which is what
he called his so-called death group and
so what he would do is yeah that's like
this blew out game it's a 50
day game and you get like invited into
this club personally but once you get
selected by one of these administrators
and what they do is every single day
they give you a task it starts starts
off easy like walk slowly across the
street or watch this scary movie or
things like that like simple test but
then as the day's progress
the challenges get more and more crazier
and to prep you for like that last
moment or something exactly how old are
these kids that they're young guys like
11 - like 18 11 you - you're not
thinking kids all thinking like
six-year-olds a lot of young people have
suicidal thoughts now yeah and so
apparently Russia is like one of the
highest 14 suicides so it's like there's
a lot of cold air because of the weather
and like believing seasonal depression -
is point where they still don't be
Korean Japan no we [ __ ] got you bear
no no that will look like he's frozen to
death already
I don't know they have White Walkers in
[ __ ] Russia yeah and so like people
draw like a lot of whales and they post
blue whales on their social media sites
kind of like that's a dope design that's
what I was just thinking dude
well looks like a great seafood
restaurant the sleepy whale and then
like they're cutting into their arms
like that's one of the tests that they
have to do that's really good that's
pretty good like this girl shoes from
Barcelona and like her family comes out
about her involvement in this game just
in times of danger that's better than my
paper drawings I think it's very curious
about the whole you know want to play a
game you could just skip all the [ __ ]
and then jump off a bridge
well it's like what are you what they're
saying is that they they like prime
these kids they're not sure yet
till they go through all the steps and
then it becomes a definite thing so
they're saying that the guys that really
don't want to kill themselves then at
the end of the game they don't well I
guess yeah I feel like I want to know
how many kids played the game is it you
stupid I thought I wanted to kill myself
don't you guys want to kill yourself man
you're so young it's too early do die
eventually he's like dying young is the
best like that's what Philip is to me
guys
he's telling all his victims like you
know you're you're gonna wear I'm gonna
collect all of you guys and create a
squad like in the afterlife and crazy
[ __ ] like that but then he's telling
authorities that yeah
and he's telling authorities yeah
they're biological waste I'm actually
just cleansing Society like I think I
was too smart as a kid somewhere
approached me like that I play well how
come we're not dying then how come we're
not dead if you think that's that death
is so awesome
get down it was a lot of these kids that
kind of started it but then they realize
like this is stupid they'll back out I
don't even need to start that [ __ ] I'll
be five resolved you're done we're not
dead I didn't buy any example
[ __ ] yeah so like give me a lot
of pop another thing that I read is that
there's apparently an app that can be
downloaded to play like downloading this
app immediately
well you download after I finish it's a
good boy let me pick let me tell you
apparently hacks your phone and collects
all your personal information and they
can use it against their victims and if
their victims back down they threatened
the victim saying we have all your
information we know who your family is
we're gonna come after you so you have
to kill yourself and that's how they
call me so yeah I think the important
thing to teach kids is like a lot of
people they stress education and
academics and arts I think the first
thing you gotta teach kids is common
sense if you got strong common sense you
know how to funnel all other education
that you're getting who gives a [ __ ] if
you're [ __ ] a classical pianist master
and you fall for a trick like this ya
should create another game that's like
why you should live game like step one
get out of your house
step two do something different and play
with basketball or something you can
just slowly kill yourself with food food
now you know yo-yo eventually died from
like
heart attack but at least you're eating
some bomb-ass food on the way yeah I'm
saying that is a body is really
resilient it's gonna take a long time
because there is this one thing I saw
there's this TV show called my life at
600 pounds so damn I can't get to 600
pounds though you guys agree with the
whole cleansing theme though like if
you're like I don't know what his theory
is but maybe his pitches if you're dumb
enough to fall for this then you should
have move anyways and we're just
cleansing my world of people that are
dumb know pretty much what you think is
like these people are not gonna do any
good to our society something I don't
think they're already suicidal anyways I
think sad people aren't the ones that do
the worst people then not so much oh
yeah well that's me
but you know the ppb all of the [ __ ]
though I don't know I never really had
like crazy suicide thoughts so it's hard
for me to relate to the suicide aspect I
did but I mean then it was just like I
I'm not down yeah it was like a save
when you're like a teen you're depressed
your whole life is it everybody went
through that I never thought about
killing myself but I sure as [ __ ]
thought about running the [ __ ] away
though I'm gonna run away I'm trying to
kill myself dude I did and then I found
drugs and I said oh this is worth living
for some drugs ya know cuz then you hear
about all these heroin overdose no
that's the thing that's to die happy tho
dollars shuttin that's not even real
happiness
okay that's like people that are bored
with their lives and then they just
every weekend they just drink and party
and then they go back to like working
where they don't want to work and
they're just trapped in this matrix oh
yeah that's called real life yes sir
I would be pretty sad to live every day
I woke up I realized I didn't have a
damn friend oh it's pretty sad that's
pretty [ __ ] sad but then I think like
what kind of what kind of parent are you
cannot give your kid the right social
skills to understand other people and
the busy parent maybe maybe there's just
a single parent that's working really
hard and they don't have time to be
there for their kid because they're just
too busy trying to feed their kid so
it's not really their fault okay well I
feel like a piece of trash now
anyways no but my mom was busy as stuff
too but hey we bonded every now and then
have you seen it no I'm sure now [ __ ]
fantastic I wear flip-flops it's not a
single mom either that's right got that
got my pops yeah used to beat my ass too
I'm just trying to be positive here and
say that something good can't come from
something bad all the time it just
depends on how long you stay in the bad
don't bring us your schools we're not
gonna help you out at all whatsoever
yeah kids don't do drugs cuz selling it
is way better what are you talking about
it's not true don't do it just sell it
you know the joys of [ __ ] having the
money is better than getting high
exactly look at Rumble Johnson MMA
fighter one of the dopest [ __ ]
powerful fire fighters to this day
decided to quit and it made to start up
a weed business that's why he quit
because he realized that making money
it's better than getting punched stop
missing out on all of the JK news
uploads don't forget to subscribe so you
know when the videos are coming up and
for the last video click over here